-My next guest
is a talented actor
who stars in the big new film
"Jungle Cruise,"
which is in theaters
and on Disney+
with premiere access
on July 30th.
Please welcome Edgar Ramirez!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Edgar Ramirez,
you can do no wrong ♪
♪ when it comes to fashion,
you got your Versace on ♪
♪ Edgar Ramirez,
you know you can't lose ♪
♪ When you're Aguirre
in that "Jungle Cruise" ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Welcome back.
-Whoa. Thank you so much.
Oh, my God.
This is so, oh, energizing.
Thank you, guys.
-It is. Right?
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoa. See? Wow.
I mean, to be here
back in New York
and back with an audience.
-I know! It's happening.
It's all good.
-Wow.
-Is this your first time back
in New York since "The Undoing"?
-Yes.
I mean, I'm just very happy.
"The Undoing" was a love letter
to New York.
It was the last time I was here.
-What would you think?
Because --
We got so into "The Undoing."
-Thank you.
-I was getting into, like,
heated debates about who did it
and what's going on.
But everyone was -- Everyone
in the world was watching it.
-Yeah.
-And you get Nicole Kidman.
-Yeah, your -- your --
-She's my friend, yeah.
And -- Yeah, sorry.
-And your --
-Anyway, yeah, it's all good.
-Your would've-been wife.
-Everything's good.
Everything's good.
-You have no idea
how many times
I've watched that YouTube video.
-Oh, well, you know, after
the first time, you're good.
You know?
-Do you still have cheese
and crackers to offer ladies
when they're...
-But Hugh Grant.
-Oh, yeah. He was amazing.
-Yeah, I dated Hugh Grant,
as well,
and no one talks about that.
But everybody was phenomenal.
You were phenomenal
in this thing.
-Thank you very much.
Thank you.
The funny thing is that
I had people --
a lot of people, you know,
coming to me and saying,
"You were so good
at playing this cop.
I mean, we love the show,
and you play them all the time.
I mean, you're so good
at playing them."
-Playing a cop.
And I would say, "But it's the
first time that I play a cop."
Like, I've never
played it before.
It was the first time.
-But you're so good at it,
they think --
-No, but then, yeah.
Talking about -- I've played
a lot of criminals before.
And I remember earlier
in my career, people would say,
"Aren't you afraid
to get pigeonholed
because you're playing
these criminals?"
And I said, "No, I mean,
they're characters,
and, you know,
they're three-dimensional."
And now I play one cop,
and then even journalists
come and say,
"I mean, you're so well --
you're so good playing them.
You play them all the time."
It's the only time
that I played a cop.
-What's your next role?
-It is a cop.
[ Laughter ]
-This is how it happens!
You put it out there!
You put it --
-You put it out there once.
-You put it out there,
and that's it now!
-Exactly.
-No, you've got --
You've done everything.
I have some photos here.
I just want to know your...
-Oh, my God.
-...stories behind some of your
costars that you've worked with.
Talk to me about De Niro.
-You know, he's a man
of very few words.
-Oh, I know.
-You know, right?
-Yeah, he's been
on the show many times.
-Yeah, exactly.
Even in interviews. We've done
a couple of movies together,
and we've been paired up
for junkets,
I mean, for interviews.
And sometimes -- Many times,
they will come
and ask him questions,
and he would say, like,
"You know what?
Edgar has a better answer
to that question.
Edgar, bring it home."
-How about --
We love Jennifer Garner.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Tell me the first thing
that comes to your mind.
-She's a very organized lady.
Yeah, yeah.
She's very organized
because she's very busy.
So, you know,
she's a full-time mom.
-Yeah, she's a great mom.
-She's a CEO, she's a business
woman, she's a producer.
-Yeah.
-You know?
And, of course, a great actress.
So, she has -- I remember
when we were doing "Yes Day,"
our comedy on Netflix,
last year.
I always saw her during
the breaks with an iCal
with a computer on the calendar
and with a planner
that was a notebook.
And then I would ask her,
"Jennifer, how do you --
I mean, why do you have --
Isn't one calendar enough?
I mean, why do you have two?"
"No, because I have to
correlate them, you know,
like, the bigger events.
I put them here,
and then there's more things,
I put them here."
It was an amazing system.
And then she got me
my first planner.
And -- Yeah.
-I'm almost tearing up.
I'm almost --
I'm getting emotional.
-Yeah, no, yeah, yeah.
It's true.
I have it. I have it.
I mean, I haven't
correlated it yet.
But I have it, man,
and I'm hopeful.
-Baby steps.
I love how organized.
That's great.
And how about this gentleman?
This is Dwayne Johnson.
-Ah, Dwayne Johnson.
-This is Dwayne Johnson.
-He's incredible.
You're right. You're right.
That guy, I mean, he lights up
the room when he walks in.
-He really does.
-Yeah, he's so full of
gratitude, and he's great.
You know, he's very,
very compassionate.
I remember when shortly before
we started "Jungle Cruise,"
I went to Iceland, and I had
an accident and I broke a rib.
So, yeah.
And like two weeks or 10 days
leading up to starting this
big movie and doing some stunts.
And the rib healed. I mean,
thank God it healed quickly.
But I remember when I --
when we started
doing the stunts, and he said,
"Edgar, don't worry.
I got you.
I mean, you have no idea.
Do you have any idea
how many bones I've broken?
I mean, it's like,
I know exactly how it feels,
so I'm going to help you."
And he's that kind of guy.
-Yeah, he's that kind of guy.
-He's gigantic, too,
so I'm happy that he helped me.
-Well, this movie is giant.
"Jungle Cruise." When Disney
does it, they do it giant.
-Yeah. It's big, yeah.
It's based on the ride,
and you have all these --
-The first ride ever made,
by the way, in Disney World.
-In Disney World.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, in the mid-'50s.
-And you have a --
You have a giant --
-What is that?
-Well, you have snakes crawling
through your face in this movie.
-Oh, yeah, I know, I know.
And do I love them.
-Yeah. It's pretty creepy.
Were you around
any real snakes during this?
-No, no, no. Thank God, no.
No, I hate -- I hate --
I don't hate them.
I'm very respectful of snakes.
[ Laughter ]
-That is in case
any snakes are watching.
-Yeah, I don't -- Yeah, exactly.
I don't want to --
-Very respectful.
-Yeah, I'm very respectful
of snakes,
and I've had
very crazy experiences
with snakes,
you know, like growing up.
We would find snakes
in the backyard,
and we would find snakes
even rolled up in the toilet.
So can you imagine
my level of trauma?
-No.
-Yeah.
But that's what happens
with actors in movies.
Then suddenly,
you are very respectful...
"scared" of snakes.
And then suddenly, yeah,
you're playing
this amazing role,
with Emily Blunt.
-Snakes all over you.
-And snakes all over you.
-And Emily Blunt, yeah.
-Exactly.
-But that's what acting is,
ladies and gentlemen.
That's what I'm talking about
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're one of the best, pal.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Edgar Ramirez
in "Jungle Cruise."
Take a look at this.
-What's going on?
-That's what I was trying
to tell you.
♪♪
[ Snake hissing ]
-No.
♪♪
-[ Speaking native language ]
-It's impossible.
♪♪
-The myth is real.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Edgar Ramirez!
"Jungle Cruise" is in theaters
and on Disney+
with premiere access July 30th.